[Musique]
paris contre 61 clubs différents du club
des choses au club des fumeuses de pipe
ou au club des timides
le club des solitaires lui a cette
particularité conseiller crasse un sage
n'at-il pas dit c'est au milieu de la
foule qu'on se sent seul quoi qu'il en
soit si solitaire triés sur le volet
rêver du titre envié semble-t-il demi
solitude pourquoi elles l'ont dit
maintenant en apprenant par les
productions de tous les pétanqueurs
jamais qui fera le bonheur est
l'heureuse élue quentin stèle pourquoi
étiez-vous candidates au titre de miss
solitude pourquoi être liste au likoud
et bien encore fait nicolas à la pioche
pour commettre des meurtres
votre programme est en bonne voie
oui je le pense
le programme demi solitude en effet nous
parut en bonne voire en très bonne voie
même qui donc a dit l'homme n'est pas
fait pour vivre salle les solitaires non
plus
[Musique]